going to the movies isn't cheap these
days but sometimes finishing a flick
just isn't worth it or even possible
movies have the power to move us in many
ways including out of our seats and
straight to the exit signs the following
films forced audience members to bail
before the credits rolled thanks to
disturbing content nauseating
cinematography and in one case utter
boredom the house that Jack built Danish
director Lars von Trier is known for
making dark upsetting art house fare
that celebrated and denounced in equal
measure he's also known for causing a
stir at the Cannes Film Festival AFP
reported that at least four people
fainted in 2009 during the Cannes
screening of his experimental horror
film Antichrist but his 2018 showing at
can was his most controversial yet the
independent reported more than 100 walk
outs in the middle of the house that
Jack built which stars Matt Dillon as a
child mutilating serial killer one
disgusted movie goer told deadlines it
was like spending two hours in hell the
film still received a standing ovation
from those left in attendance with one
guardian critic raving that the finale
in particular was quote spectacular
Cloverfield the 2008 found-footage
horror film Cloverfield follows six
Manhattan Millennials attending a party
when a gigantic monster attacks the city
their experience is shakily documented
on a personal video camera later
recovered by the Department of Defense
audience members reportedly bailed left
and right during clover fields
record-breaking opening weekend
complaining of migraines nausea and
motion sickness caused by the film's
unsettling cinematography a few soldiers
some theaters even posted warning signs
comparing watching the film to riding a
roller coaster inherent vice director
Paul Thomas Anderson has amassed a
considerable amount of cred with critics
and casual moviegoers alike with films
such as Boogie Nights and there will be
blood but his star-studded 2014
adaptation of Thomas Pynchon's
70s noir novel inherent vice
caused enough audience walkouts for the
media to take notice thanks to the power
of Twitter Steve Rose at The Guardian
wrote about the online reaction in a
piece
subtitled how to make a film your
audience will be dying to leave Rose
gathered several walkout tweets from
prominent UK writers baffled by the
joaquin phoenix LED flick including one
from novelist Philip incher who tweeted
understood so little of plot or dialogue
I worried I'd had a stroke but it wasn't
an isolated phenomenon Rose reported
that the internet was buzzing with
similar reports including saw inherent
vice and at least a quarter of the
audience walked out I couldn't sit
through more than an hour of inherent
vice and 50% walk out rate is highest
I've seen in a while many viewers found
the dark comedy incomprehensible and
boring but a lot of critics were
impressed with the movie calling it a
faithful adaptation of the equally
puzzling source material if you're
willing to put in the time Jordan
Hoffman from Vanity Fair advises it's
far more rewarding if you watch it twice
the revenant Leonardo DiCaprio finally
won his first Academy Award for his
starring role in the brutal wilderness
revenge epic the revenant but when the
film was first screened for Awards
voters in November 2015
many Academy members and attendants
reportedly couldn't handle the movie's
more gruesome moments including the now
famous bear attack
Scott Feinberg of The Hollywood Reporter
noted several people walked out
throughout the movie apparently unable
to take the gore film historian and
critic Leonard Maltin later expressed
doubts about the film's chances for
Oscar glory explaining the older members
of the Academy will accept a certain
amount of violence if the balance of the
film pleases them but if as they leave
the theater the lingering thought is how
violent it was that can be a detriment
in the case of the revenant several
Academy members left the theater early
because of the violence but director
Alejandro G and yadi too still won his
fourth Oscar and the film was nominated
in 12 categories the most of any film
that year